Abdel Basset al Megrahi family have long
pushed to prove his innocence now eight
years after his death and more than
thirty years after the Lockerbie tragedy
they've got a chance
the Scottish criminal cases Review
Commission has decided the conviction
can be referred to the High Court for
appeal for the third time we had
identified six grounds for referring the
case to the Appeal Court and the
Commission has gone on to deliver a
damning indictment of the process and
they believe that a miscarriage of
justice may have occurred by reason of
an unreasonable verdict and the ground
of non disclosure Pan Am flight 103 was
blown up over the Scottish town of
Lockerbie in December 1988 it was
enroute from London to New York and most
of the 270 victims were American the US
relatives were satisfied when in 2001
former Libyan intelligence officer Abdul
Basit al Megrahi
was jailed for life for the attack he
always said he was innocent and some
Scottish victims families have
campaigned for years to clear him and
find out who was involved on Wednesday
Jim Swire whose daughter was killed gave
a written reaction read out by his
lawyer for me this case is about two
families mine and Abdul Bassets behind
them now are seen to lie the needs of 25
other families in applying for a further
appeal 31 years after the event itself
we need the truth al Megrahi first
appealed his conviction in 2002 but this
was refused by Scotland's High Court the
next year as the West started to rebuild
trade ties with Libya then leader
Moammar Ghadafi accepted his country's
responsibility for the bombing he paid
compensation to the victims families but
all along some believe there was
stronger evidence Iran was behind the
bombing months after 290 died when a
u.s. warship brought down an Iranian
passenger plane
in 2009 al-megrahi dropped his appeal
and was allowed to fly home on
compassionate grounds he had terminal
cancer he died in 2012 McGraw his family
have always described to us the 270
first Lockerbie victim they say his last
words were about fighting for justice
now that fight has been given a new
lease of life nadine barber al jazeera